all right marty
yes marty welcome back yes thank you for
having me back so your your last talk
was so
powerful
i think it was one of my favorites i've
ever done
maybe my very favorite because it wasn't
the story was so great your story was
similar to a lot of the ones i've done
but the way you
the message that you shared at the end
was so on target with what i'm trying to
do with this channel that it was just
like
it was like the perfect video thank you
so much in terms of how you know even
your storytelling skills
were amazing um
how did you i mean how
because there are so many people i've
interviewed who have been through
similar childhoods yes
and have ended up addicted to drugs and
lost and homeless
and just self-destructing
worse and worse every day
you've clearly like not done that
some something you know you have the
clarity and the wherewithal to somehow
pull yourself out of where you could
have gone right and get to where you are
today i mean so you're working you have
a job yes
your life is together there's no drugs
there's no nothing
no no drugs i uh
live on my own um
i'm very independent in every sense of
the word and i'm beyond proud of that
uh
yeah i don't have it all the way
together for sure i'm not perfect and i
don't
i don't aim to be
i just uh
i'm a huge believer in
self-love
you know i i think that
yes i had an extremely extremely rough
childhood but
i believe that
[Music]
um when you're a kid and when you're a
teenager
adults are responsible for you
but once you become an adult
i fully fully believe that it is your
responsibility
to
seek
knowledge wherever you can find it
whether
you know
education i think it's the most crucial
thing for people whether that's um
whether that's school or whether that's
you know
you picking up gems
throughout life
because you know you're gonna you're
gonna mess up
you know but
the beauty of messing up is that it's
teaching you a lesson
you know so i try my best to whenever
i'm going through hard things
or dealing with a i don't know any kind
of bad situation or if i mess up on
something
i always ask myself
well
what did did i do something to
to make the situation go bad
or
okay this sucks but
what can i learn from it
you know i i truly believe with all my
heart that there's always something
positive you can take from something
you know
how did you come
about i mean it's a common
belief but how did you come to
forgiveness as the answer to
your situation
ah yeah i know you saw a therapist um
[Music]
you know i i can remember as a kid are
you religious
i'm not super religious
but
i do feel like i have a strong
connection to god yes i'm not religious
at all but yeah there's nobody that
believes in forgiveness more than i do
yeah like like um
like there's a lot of things in the
bible that i have questions for you know
so that's why i can't say that i'm
i'm beyond religious you know all i know
is that
i believe in my heart that there's
something bigger than me that is uh
that's been there for me this entire
time or because i i really feel like
we all need to either believe in
something or have faith in something
um or hope in in
in something better
you know and
whether that's god for you or or whether
that's uh someone else that you idolize
uh
it doesn't matter at the end of the day
search for your hope
search for your faith so search for
something that you believe in like you
said you believe
in forgiveness you know and
if you believe in that you'll start
searching for it yeah it's really just i
think forgiveness is i mean it came from
my belief
in my appetite for learning
yes you and i talked about yes
yeah i mean learning is just
yeah i think we never stop learning and
for sure by really kind of trying to
figure out situations and relationships
and things like that you learn that
forgiveness is really the solution oh
definitely i absolutely believe in that
because literally everything it it uh
okay so when i was a kid um
you know i always wanted an adult to
kind of like save me i guess in assault
in a sense or or someone
um
to guide me give me guidance uh
i crave um
i crave knowledge
you know and
every time i have something i don't know
for example
i
i used to have really massive anger
issues
and
you know i didn't have anybody around me
that would be
that would teach me how to work on my
anger so
you know i started asking myself okay
well what what's making you angry
let's write that down
and
how can we
what's the opposite of this you know how
can we fix this um let's do some
research you know now you have your
phone you know you have your computer
you can google everything like so easy
to learn now yes so so if you
if you have a question about yourself
whether that's
anger issues whether that's depression
um
anxiety ptsd
even even how to be more
i don't know
like
uh how to keep your house together how
to how to
you know have things organized you can
research all those things you know
and and i come from a place where
a lot of the adults failed me growing up
and i think that
i just one day really looked at myself
and i said
okay
no one around you seems to help you
and now
you're old enough to help yourself
so let's figure that out
you know
yeah it's like you're taking
responsibility for yourself yes like a
lot of these people that i interview are
victims and they oh poor me and
they don't see any
anybody they're looking for somebody to
come save them and even if that happened
i've kind of inserted myself as the i'm
going to save you i'm going to give you
everything you need the education the
the the housing the transportation
everything you need so you can get your
life straight
they still they still mess it up yeah
they reject it or they or they just
they don't want to succeed yes they
don't want to take responsibility for
their own lives
and do the work
but you somehow seem to at some point
took responsibility for your your
happiness
yes because because i realized that um
i realize that
you're responsible for the outcome of
your life
you hold that power
you you can't control the outside world
you you have no control over that so
i told myself
okay try to let that stress go because
you can't control what people say or do
so
but you can control this
you can control your mind make
whatever it is that you truly want in
your mind
try to make that the world you you
surround yourself with you know like if
you if you want to be more positive
surround yourself by positive people
um
if you want to you know achieve any goal
again research
you know
i i can't stress that enough just
um
and self-awareness
self-awareness
it's gonna get ugly for sure
because
you have to ask yourself
okay
i went through this trauma
but i'm not going through the trauma
anymore yes i am struggling with ptsd
and anxiety
but
how
how am i contributing to my own misery
and
that's a hard question to ask yourself
because
because you know
you're not being consistent
you're not being responsible
you're
i was drinking a lot
you know just to just to get away from
all the craziness
and that just caused me
more more drama
um
[Music]
definitely
you know struggling financially because
instead of saving my money i'm out
spending it on
i don't know going out and having a good
time which there's nothing wrong with
having a good time here and there but
if your life's not on track
it's your fault is not on track
because
it's selfish to ask someone else to
to take care of you
when you're an adult
you can ask for help yes
there's the difference
you know sometimes you can't do
everything by yourself so it's it's okay
to ask for help
but
if you're just asking someone can you
please do for me do for me do for me
but you're not doing for yourself you're
not making that effort to
to work on your betterment daily
no matter what
kind of effort people try
to give you it's it's not going to go
anywhere because the work needs to start
in here
you're a big fan of therapy
a huge huge huge fan of therapy i can't
oh man therapy i i truly believe saved
my life
i
how old were you when you started 21 or
21. 21 yeah how many years did you
maybe like six six years how often would
you go i would go every week just once
and i i
went once a week and then they would
offer like um group therapies and i'll i
will sign up for everything
you know it was so it's so hard again
it's not going to be easy
but you have to get uncomfortable
in order
to overcome those things
you know it's it's it's this wall you
have in front of you
um
[Music]
for example i i remember we we had like
a an art
therapy group
and
they asked to uh draw
what we were feeling
and i
i
i can't draw to save my life first of
all
but i tried
um
i drew
a person holding
some
what seemed like
like bars like in a jail
and looking forward
and looking sad and behind the person
was a door
by first glance
you think that the person is in prison
right
or or you know their own personal prison
i should say
but
you don't realize that there's a door
behind you the entire time
and
if you only believe in yourself enough
you'll notice the door
you know
and that's what i feel like therapy is
like you know you gotta
you gotta get rid of those bars man and
and
you'll only be able to do that when you
confront what you're most afraid of you
know whether i was afraid of
i was afraid of being embarrassed
of of the shame
of
you know
yeah that's the biggest thing it's just
being ashamed and being embarrassed
because when you first start you think
that everything was your fault and it's
not you know and you
and it's okay
to say it's it's not your fault
you know and talk about it the more you
talk about
things the
the lighter you'll feel
yeah not getting it off your chest for
sure getting it out of the closet
definitely because if you give the power
yeah if you continue to uh
hold things in
you're just
you're carrying all this weight and
eventually you know it's like if you're
if you're carrying a bunch of things and
you're walking and you're walking and
you're still caring and you're still
carrying it you're there's no place but
down because it's getting heavier
and unless you do the work for yourself
at some point your face is gonna hit the
pavement
and you gotta love yourself more than
that
have you always been
you're you're you're a very positive
person have you always been positive oh
no no
no no no um you know i had a moment
where like i said hurt people hurt
people oh that's right yeah like i i was
very violent um in that five-year
relationship i was also verbally abusive
uh
you know i uh
i had anger issues
and um
i had zero patience like you can say
anything and i snap
you know
and uh
and i was always like
i'm not doing that because
this is gonna go bad
i'm not doing that because this is gonna
go bad and
it's almost like you're you're living
your life in defense mode
but
it worked for me when i was a kid when i
needed it
i no longer need that
and
i don't know how i got to the point
where i saw that i didn't
i didn't
need to be on defense mode anymore
um
but i'm glad i
i found it yeah
there's a there's a quote i think i
think it's abraham lincoln said people
are only as happy as they want to be
yeah it's a choice
it's a choice you you should i see that
very clearly from doing this channel
i've learned
like you read the comments you'll see
some people just wanna
you know criticize and judge and and be
miserable and share their misery and
make everyone else around them miserable
and then other people are very kind of
supportive and helpful and giving hope
and
all kinds of different support
you know encouragement
and it's very clear like
some of these people want to be
miserable and that's not going to change
because they they're they're hell bent
on being miserable and other people are
just very positive and they're going to
stay that way and there's not much you
can do to
change the
direction that these people are going in
so it's like some people want to be
happy and other people want to be
miserable yeah and there's not much you
can do about that i think i think
i think it's uh
um
well for me when i when i hear people's
hear other people tell their stories
or or when i hear
negative criticism about me
um
i i try my best to be open-minded i
always try to put myself in somebody
else's shoes because
uh for example like you can be at a
store and someone bumps into you right
and
and your first reaction could be watch
where you're going you know
and that person can go off on you you
don't know
but
be mindful that
what if
what if they just lost someone
what if um
[Music]
what if they're thinking about how in
the world am i going to pay my rent this
month
or
damn it i really hate my job
or
my
my kid is sick and i have no idea how
i'm going to
you know
get their medicine because
it's so expensive it's a million
yes and
my point is you you don't know what
other people are going through
so
i try to remind myself of that
so i can stay open-minded and so i can
have
so i can lead with compassion
that's my
the biggest thing i work on every day is
compassion is kindness and
open-mindedness
i don't
[Music]
i just feel like
i needed
when i was a kid i needed an adult so
badly that now that i am an adult i want
to be that adult that i needed so badly
and
i think that
that's what we need to do you know
yeah back to what you were just saying
about other people and interactions yes
if people understood how
so many people are operating out of fear
and shame yes and if you just understand
that maybe that's why they're behaving
the way they are for sure
you'll you'll see things so much more
clearly
you don't have you don't you'll have a
little bit more patience yeah you don't
need to know the exact facts and details
yeah you just have to know that maybe
they're going through something they're
so afraid of or ashamed of or something
like that that makes them behave in this
crazy way right
yeah definitely you have a lot of
courage you've you've overcome a lot and
your attitude is so so great thank you
so much i appreciate that
what do you think is uh
the key to that i mean is it just your
thirst for knowledge
i think so i i think that uh
common sense because
yeah i feel like um you know like i said
i i
i feel like my education was robbed for
me when i was a kid so
i can
you don't you don't have control over
those things when you're when you're
younger you know your education is on
your phone now yeah i research
everything and and then i listen to uh
things that motivate me things that that
inspire me you know i you gotta
you gotta be mindful of what you feed
your mind
if you continue to watch negative things
what do you think your mind is gonna be
filled up
if you watch positive things positive
stories things that
you know people that are over that
overcame you know
crazy crazy things
remind yourself that if they're human if
they can do it you can do it too
you know and and if you don't have
a role model or
or a friend or
um
a sibling
that
that's positive in your life
search for one
you know
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in your life
you've learned a lot so
to love yourself
love yourself
we
we we are our own worst critic
and
just learn how to be compassionate with
yourself
no one knows your needs more than you do
and pay attention to that and
your mental health
i feel like is the number one most
important thing absolutely and you have
to
daily nurture that
take care of that and
take the time take the time to do that
loving yourself would
will change
everything
i promise
all right
mari thank you so much for coming back
thank you and your
your first talk in this talk are both so
interesting to me thank you so much
appreciate it thank you all right thank
you thank you
thank you so much
you